[Music]
all right one more question then we're
done
one more okay so we'll make this the
final question
good day happy sabbath
i am a married woman okay i'm reading
the question okay i am a married woman
that is baptized in the seventh-day
adventist church and my husband has
betrayed me
and is in america and he has an outside
child as well as is involved in several
extramarital relationships
i would like to know if he divorces me
in order to get his paper straightened
will i be free from that marriage
contract can i
marry again to another man
thank you and please pray for me and my
children as i go through a hard time
dealing with the betrayal and acceptance
move forward with my life the answer is
she is absolutely free to remember yes
now god hates separation divorce you
name it malachi 2 16 the lord of israel
he hates putting away but he's given us
provision the condition is violation of
the contract yes she's absolutely free
to remember and the church recognizes
them
short answer she's
now i'm not promoting that
calvary promotes reconciliation but
sometimes some situations are almost
beyond reconciliation reclamation or
redemption all i'm saying is biblically
she has the right to remarry and based
on our church's standards she has the
right to remember she's free
assuming she did not do what the husband
did
yes she's free freeze the birth but
every effort should be made to fix
broken situations
romans 12 18 if it be possible as much
as life then you live peacefully with
all men
and if anything needs peace sometimes
there's a lot of marriages they have no
peace
as much as life in you what she must be
able to say is i have done everything i
could to save this thing and i failed i
have done everything i could you can say
that you're perfectly free even if you
don't say you're still free but god will
judge your heart that's what i'm saying
do everything you can to see
but you are free yes to marry if he dies
if he goes off and marry someone else he
is not free
he is not free but you are
because he's the offending one the
offending one must remain single all the
days of his own life
the innocent party can remember
if reconciliation seems impossible
some people are so damaged emotionally
that it's better for them to just
separate
but we must not force on them you have
to stay we can't force that on people
because we don't know exactly what
they're feeling and the depth of
devastation we don't know
but the bible provides me yes this makes
you free
god is sorry it has to happen but you
can remarry
and if that's what you choose may the
lord grant you the happiness you didn't
have
i mean the lord saved that man because
god does not want to see anyone lost
all right here it ends the lesson sister
dr donation
ah thank you so much elder skeet what a
time what a time did we have together
discussing the word of god
telling us a sweet time thank you so
much for your you're welcome
thank you i'll just keep may god
continue to bless you
your wife and entire family
and may the light of the lord continue
to shine upon you and may he renew or
even change your strength
okay so that you will continue to work
for the lord and i do pray and hope that
you also get some physical rest yes yes
i do i do my lovely sister i do thanks
for that and may god bless you all those
who work with you
uh in the work you do i i really i
really like this program that god has
placed on your heart
to start and may continue for a long
while and i hope those who tune in are
blessed i really bless enlightened
if i was a little hard sometimes forgive
me but sometimes
anyway may god bless all those who heard
it
and i want to encourage people study the
bible
many times i get questioned by email and
i'm quite sure the person has not really
made an effort and sometimes they say
have you studied this for yourself
bible study is fellowship with god
by not studying you miss time with god
personally
don't just say whether the text is
difficult try study it spend time ask
the spirit to open your mind compare
this verse with that verse look up a
particular word from genesis or
revelation it takes time but the
benefits are beyond calculation
make an effort to study for yourself
that's when you get the spiritual truth
when the spirit has spoken to you and
you have seen it and when god makes a
revelation i tell you my listening
friend you don't want to jump and shout
you can't sit still when the spirit
shows you something
it's an experience you must have you
don't get it by having someone else tell
you which has its place but when the
holy spirit shows you as a reward for
your effort to learn ah
it's a tremendous experience and you
must not miss it but it only comes when
we try to understand
and so thanks dr persian
for this privilege to be a part of this
very blessed program god bless you and
your studies
and may he use you to be a blessing to
others
thanks again
amen thank you so much elder skeet for
pronouncing that blessing i claim it and
receive it in jesus name all right okay
so you know since i'm doing thanks and
elder skeet we cannot thank you enough
for your time and for your presence
we say thank you we say thank you i'm i
extend special thanks to also brother
jonathan david archie for asking the
questions adding commentary being here i
know he's
very busy but he took time to be here i
thank god also and express thanks for
brother kevin gomez in advance for
ministering our meditation song
thank you brother gomez for taking this
time out to be with us and thank you in
advance carissa hunt for doing the
closing prayer
for all of you that are on right now
that have been asking questions putting
your comments in the chat thank you so
much for spending this time with us and
i really do pray that you are not only
blessed and enlightened but that we've
taken away some gems that we can apply
to our lives and share with others so
feel free to share this word the uh this
session has been live stream so it's up
on youtube it's up on facebook so you
can share this link with your loved ones
so that perhaps their questions would be
answered because we covered a lot of
open forum questions i also express
thanks to my mom thank you mom for your
support words of counsel and wisdom and
also to because an arrow who's on who
always assists with the technology and
so forth and i already said thank you to
sister stacy but thank you sister stacy
and for also moderating the chat and all
of you that are on i could name friends
with son and those of you that have been
sharing the word thank you for your time
and your presence and by god's grace we
will meet again december 25
um so-called christmas that's what's
being celebrated on that day by the
world december 25th at 2 o'clock p.m
eastern standard time we are having a q
a by god's grace on babylon on babylon
so this sabbath we spoke about the
remnant church
next month the fourth sabbath god
willing we'll be speaking about babylon
so
i'm going to turn it over to you brother
gomez to minister to us in song and
friends as you listen to the words of
the song just meditate on one what the
song is saying when two on things that
we've we we have learned today we spoke
especially about having a personal
indwelling practical relationship with
god letting the word really work upon
our hearts and upon our lives you know
allowing god to change us
so that we won't just be preaching the
gospel with our lips but we'll be
preaching with our lives so i pray that
that will be on our thoughts and our
minds as we go throughout
not only the rest of the sabbath day but
even our christian journey
so brother kevin gomez
all over
to you
praise god gentle savior
lead me home thank you so much brother
gomez for
just outpouring your heart through that
song
may our prayer be that god our gentle
savior even jesus christ will lead
us home sister chrissa
please take us to the throne of grace
alrighty thank you amen let's borrow our
heads
dear heavenly
wonderful father thank you lord so much
for this time that we had together
um communion with you fellowship in your
word getting into your word and having
our burning questions answered we thank
you so much for your holy spirit that
guides us through these sessions
we thank you father for your love and
your care towards us the father
we pray for your help to love and obey
your word and to keep your commandments
we know that when we obey that we will
receive power from you
please make a way for us to obey you in
all things some things may look how we
sometimes we may be perplexed on how to
obey with a certain situation but the
father you are able to make a way please
make a way for us and help us to walk in
the way that you have made if any idols
that are in our lives that are taking
the place of you
we pray that you help us to turn away
from them
and help us to surrender to you
completely dead lord
thank you for the joy
the power the security
and the insurmountable blessings that we
receive through obedience
we pray for an outpouring of your holy
spirit and each of us each individual
listening in our families that we may
bear good fruit and be a witness for
jesus christ spreading the gospel
please continue to be with each
individual and family member represented
continue to guide us as we occupy and
work and school and ministry and in our
homes
we pray that you bless this this this
session and the ones to come so that it
could be a witness and it could share
your truth dear lord help us to stand
for your truth continue to be prayers
for eternity bless each person listening
each household
everyone who has tuned in and who will
tuned in and we pray to meet again in
jesus name i pray amen
amen amen thank you so much sister
carissa and lord we say thank you to you
for making this possible thank you again
all of you that have tuned in
participated post your questions
even share the message